[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay. So, the DOM contains all the content of the page.
The CSSOM contains all the styles of the page. So how
do we take the content and styles and turn them onto
pixels on the screen? I feel like we're missing an intermediate step.
>> That's good intuition. Now we need to combine the
DOM and the CSSOM trees into the render tree which will
capture exactly what you described. One of the most important properties
of the render tree is that it only captures visible content.
And to see this in action, let's work through the
simple example we have in front of us. At the top,
we have the DOM tree and at the bottom the CSSOM
object model. To construct the render tree, we start at the
root of the DOM tree, which in this case is the
paragraph node and check if there is any CSS rules. That
match it. In this case, we see that we do have
a matching rule that makes all the text render in 16
pixel font size and in bold. So we
copy the paragraph node to our render tree alongside
with its CSS properties. Okay. We're done with
the paragraph node. Let's walk down the tree. Next,
we see, hello, which is just a text
node. So we copy that through our render tree.
Next we arrive at the span node. We have a matching CSS rule for it. We have
a span and it is indeed a child of the paragraph node. But notice that
one of the properties in this rule is that it's marked as display none, which
tells us that the contents of this span should not be rendered. And since as
we said the render tree only captures visible
content. We can skip it and its children.
>> We skip the children, because display,none cascades down, right?
>> Exactly. And as a result, we can skip all
the children nodes of the span node and go to the
next node, which in this case is just another text
node. And we copy that to our render tree once over.
>> So the render tree captures both the content and the styles.
>> Right. Now let's take a look at our Hello World page. Okay, here we
have the dom and CSS trees for our Hello World page. To build a render
tree we start at the HTML node in the
dom tree. The HTML and the head sections don't
contain any visible information. So we can just quickly
prune them out of our render tree. Next, we have
the body node. Let's copy that over. This left
part of the tree should look familiar. This is what
we just built. So let's copy that over as
well. Finally, we have the div and the image nodes.
Both of these contain visible content, so we
also copy them over, and their styles, into
our render tree. With that done, compare this
render tree to what we have on the screen.
>> Huh. Yeah. The render tree is a pretty good
representation. The unnecessary text is gone. I can see that there
should be an image on the screen and it should
be displayed on the right. So, are we all done now?
>> Not quite. We still have to do layout. But first a quick quiz.